kommt ihnen das blut schneller als
gedacht nach deutschland das
amerikanische unternehmen alcon hat mit
seiner deutschen niederlassung die
streckenpläne für deutschland
veröffentlicht hat die hyper logan
teststrecke in den usa gebaut und hat
jetzt einen simplen aber revolutionären
plan für deutschland dabei weshalb zum
mega öko transportmittel und zu einem
der größten produzenten regenerativer
energie in deutschland jetzt in science
fiction herzlich willkommen akon bauten
die helfer luban teststrecke in den usa
und ist als planungsbüro und
bauausführung anbauten wie dem
heimathafen doha dem flughafen abu dhabi
der antarktis forschungsstation
relegation sechs dem virgin spaceport
america und vielen vielen anderen
großbaustellen und transportsystem
beteiligt umsatz 2015 18 milliarden
dollar also wahrlich nicht irgendwer das
unternehmen nimmt an der global
challenge von hyper lavanttal bei der
mögliche strecken projektiert werden und
sie sah hyper loop ist auch in
deutschland gar nicht mal so kompliziert
umzusetzen
dabei greift er kam auf eine alte idee
zurück die ähnlich bei der ic strecke
köln-frankfurt umgesetzt wurde
als es immer wieder konkrete ansätze für
den bau eines transrapid in deutschland
knapp war eine idee den transrapid auf
stelzen in der mitte deutsche autobahnen
fahren zu lassen
die autobahn haben eine bereits für
schnellen verkehr optimierte
streckenführung und das gelände ist
schon eigentum des bundes
baugenehmigungen hätten deutlich
schneller und mit weniger widerstand aus
der bevölkerung erlangt werden können
unter anderem weil ökologische fragen
einfach nicht mehr anstehen beim bau der
ice-strecke köln-frankfurt wurde diese
idee aufgegriffen und die trasse
zumindest parallel zur autobahn gebaut
auch dabei wurde immer wieder der bau
einer transrapid strecke diskutiert da
die magnetschwebebahn größere steigungen
überwinden konnte und die strecke so
billiger geworden wäre
durch die jetzt realisierte verkehrswege
bündelung werden vor allem die
ökologischen folgen deutlich reduzierten
genau so wie jetzt auch die pläne für
den heimflug in deutschland aus es wäre
wie deutsche hyper wagen die strecke
würde als verkehrswege bündelung mit
deutschen autobahnen gebaut und wäre so
deutlich schneller realisierbar erkläre
mit rund 1900 kilometern die längste für
europa projektierte strecke und würde
ganz deutschland auf einer rennstrecke
in kürzester zeit miteinander verbinden
die fahrt von hamburg nach berlin würde
nur noch 20 minuten dauern von münchen
nach berlin nur eine stunde mit hals in
leipzig und nürnberg und zwischen köln
und hamburg würde die fahrt rund eine
halbe stunde dauern bisher sind das
alles strecken auf denen man mit den zug
mindestens vier stunden unterwegs ist
der hype wäre da ein riesenfortschritt
doch trotzdem werden
genehmigungsverfahren in deutschland
wohl besonders lange dauern durch die
bündelung mit der autobank würde zwar
beschleunigt aber eben doch deutlich
länger dauern als in anderen ländern in
südkorea plant die regierung schon 2021
ein produkt strecke zwischen 4 uhr und
do sand gebaut zu haben der vertrag mit
hyper lukits einem weiteren unternehmen
das die entwicklung vor antrag zu als
schon geschlossen
hiervon sind wir in deutschland noch
weit entfernt wohl auch weil sich im
bundesverkehrsministerium noch niemand
so richtig mit der materie beschäftigt
hat ich wollte vom ministerium wissen ob
der tunnelbau für einen hype in
deutschland vielleicht einfacher zu
genehmigen auf nachfrage war das
bundesverkehrsministerium nicht in der
lage auskunft über die rechtlichen
rahmenbedingungen eines solchen
projektes zu geben ob überhaupt anträge
für solche tunnelprojekte gestellt
werden müssen und welche das sind ist
den fachleuten dort scheinbar nicht
bekannt das ist natürlich
hochnotpeinlich nicht mal über die
rahmenbedingungen ist man dort in der
lage auskunft zu geben hoffen wir mal
dass das beim hafer bahnprojekt dann
anders ist das würde nämlich noch einen
hohen ökologischen mehrwert bieten
die planer haben einen solarzellen dafür
den hyper lud geplant und stromleitungen
parallel zur strecke sodass auch das
stromtransport problem mit dem bau der
strecke direkt gelöst ist und damit mal
eben so eine zusätzliche stromtrasse in
deutschland entsteht es dürfte damit die
größte photovoltaikanlage der welt
werden
ich finde dass das projekt eine
ernsthafte beschäftigung damit auch in
deutschland verdient hat auf warm wenn
die beamten im bundesverkehrsministerium
der weckruf gehört haben und es mit dem
bau weshalb wir in deutschland konkret
er wird erfordert natürlich hier wenn er
kein video dazu verpassen dann wird mir
hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich
den auf die glocke hier geht es weiter
also hier mit tempo 200 unterirdisch
durch die stadt eine weitere mega idee
von elena kiesling einfach draufklicken
wenn es euch interessiert was dann
bleibt dran